I'm gonna be sitting down with Tommy
Robinson this week to say Tommy's a
controversial figure would be putting it
mildly you only have to glance at his
Twitter mentions to see how some see him
as a modern-day hero defending Western
society while others see him as a racist
thug thankfully I don't get all my
information from Twitter and neither
should you
Tommy is the co-founder of the English
Defence League a movement that opposes
Islamism and Sharia law in the UK he
left the EDL a few years ago after
connecting with Majin Wozzeck William
foundation because he felt the EDL had
become too extreme now Tommy is part of
pegida UK a subset of the bigger
European pagina movement which has the
stated goal of preventing the
islamification of our countries
basically Tommy thinks that the UK and
now all of Europe are in route to
becoming Islamic nations Tommy reached
out to me about two months ago to see
about being a guest on the show before I
said yes I actually had to do a bit of
soul-searching as you guys know I'm
beyond fed up with the regressive left
labeling of everyone a bigot or a racist
but in Tommy's case are they actually
right and if the regressives are why
should I even talk to someone with
racist views there's no doubt Tommy
spends most of his time talking about
the dangers of Islam he certainly isn't
hiding that but are his motives actually
based in bigotry it wasn't just those
questions that had me unsure whether to
talk to him though there was actually
something else at work and something
that really exposes the rot that the
regressives are causing in our society
part of me was actually afraid that if I
spoke to Tommy regardless of whether he
really is a bigot or not that I also
would be labeled a bigot let me repeat
that I feared that just by having a
conversation with someone just by
hearing their views on this show as I do
every week that I would then get one of
those awful labels that people throw
around thrown on me after a couple days
of thinking about it I realized that not
only did I have to do the interview with
Tommy but my fear was the exact reason
that I had to do it the chilling effect
that words like bigoted and racist
are not just on the person at who they
are aimed but they're also used to stop
other people from talking to them the
less we talk the more the authoritarians
can move in with easy answers once I
really wrap myself around that it was a
no-brainer like all my guests all at
Tommy's ideas be heard and you the
audience will be the judge
ironically if the left had been more
honest about the dangers of Islamism all
along I would feel less of a need to
have conversations like this but they
refused to so here we are if his ideas
are good then let them spread if they
aren't then let them be beat by better
ideas as my former guest Douglas Murray
said on Sam Harris's podcast a few weeks
ago it's too late to be willing to be
blackmailed by people who are
fundamentally insincere in their insults
that's exactly how I feel about labels
or pretty much any of the other nonsense
coming from people who would rather
stifle debate than have it this past
week and i rewatch one of my all-time
favorite movies V for Vendetta in these
powerful speech to London he says and
where once you had the freedom to object
to think and speak as you saw fit you
now have censors and systems of
surveillance coercing your conformity
and soliciting your submission how did
this happen who's to blame well
certainly there are those more
responsible than others and they will be
held accountable but again truth be told
if you're looking for the guilty you
need only look in the mirror I think
it's getting high time that we all look
in the mirror and decide what we believe
my guest this week is an author activist
and former leader of the English Defence
League
he's also no stranger to controversy
Tommy Robinson welcome to the show thank
you five million all right man so I want
to start with this which is what I led
the show off with which is that I
struggled with the decision to even have
you on the show because I see what
people say about you and half of it is
this guy is gonna save the Western world
and then half of it is he's a bigot he's
a racist and plenty of other stuff in
line with that so first off do you get
that often do you get that people are
sometimes afraid to talk to you yes and
there's a reason for that you will be
targeted as has anyone else that speaks
to me no great by a campaign you will
and trust me you will I've just been
asked last night it was released I'm
going to be addressing this the Hindu
leadership of the UK I've been invited
to an event to discuss multiculturalism
they've been targeted they're getting
attacked now I expect that when I turn
up if they're not forced or pressurised
into cancelling which is what's happened
with university after university after
university with schools anyone that
asked me to speak even TV shows in the
UK there's a conservative their effort
to silence what I'm saying and to attack
anyone that gives me a platform to say
it yeah well as I mentioned at the top
that was really what my deciding factor
was to talk to you because I'm so sick
of everyone being labeled bigoted and
racist and all that that if I'm afraid
to talk to you then that that is almost
a bigger problem than bigotry and racism
so that's why we have to do this I think
yeah you're in you're in a minority that
I so thank you you are all right because
well most people put their reputations
or their careers or or things like that
before free speech in the UK yeah well
somehow I still have this belief that if
I talk about free speech that it'll
actually be good for my career
we shall see but why don't we start with
this let's just start with the most
obvious piece of meat are you bigoted
against Muslims no I try to separate
Muslims whenever I did whenever I speak
I tried to set them separate Muslims
from Islam I have an opinion on Islam in
the same way Islam has an opinion upon
me
Islam is bigoted towards non-muslims not
every Muslim of course every every
Muslim is not big-eared if you if you
read my book that some of the best meat
people I've met in my life growing up
are Muslims I don't have a problem of
Muslims but I do have a problem with the
way Islam is influenced in my country I
have a problem with the hatred days
incited from it and and we are on
fearful of what the future holds right
so just to be clear and this is what
I've spent a lot of the time on the show
talking about your making a distinction
between Islam meaning the doctrine the
set of ideas that are in books between
that and between the people that may or
may not be using these ideas and as you
said you've met plenty of Muslim people
that you like a lot and you're making
that distinction
I made that distinction in a similar way
to the fact that if I was a critic of
Scientology I would not be getting
called a racist
I would not be gang called any of the
things I am just because it happens a
majority of not of Muslims are not white
on beaten down and attacked with this
racist ich which is ridiculous because
Islam is an idea it's an idea that
should be criticized and it's my
god-given right to criticize it yeah and
I don't incite how you against
individual Muslims I've never ever yeah
I I let the English Defence League for
over six years
I've never been done for any racism any
extremism and he insightful speeches in
fact if people at the height of lead in
the English Defence League when there
was a when our soldier Lee Rigby was
beheaded in the streets of London our
very next demonstration I started my
speech off by saying that there are 600
Muslims who serve in the in the British
Armed Forces that if you attack a Muslim
woman or you get spear Muslim woman you
you're an absolute coward and I try to
get the distinction between some things
are morally just and I think my campaign
is morally just and righteous and other
things are cowardly attack in the house
is a worship whether they be Christian
or Muslim is cowardly
so from I've done that from day one in
fact as far as the organization goes
we've been a moderate voice in this in
this but we can completely attacked as
extremists or hateful and incite and
hate literally just this week I've gone
we're we're having a demonstration in
the city of Birmingham which is
Britain's second biggest city hazard as
a large Muslim population it has a lot
of problems there and I met a Muslim
councilor and this is that this is where
the problem comes in and I said to him
if an organization is completely
peaceful and there's no violence there's
no alcohol do they have a right to come
to this city and criticize Islam and he
said no and that's where we're at and I
said why not he said because criticizing
Islam incites hey I said telling the
truth can't incite hey and that's where
we're being beaten down so much because
so many and he's a counsellor for the
Labour Party which is a mainstream
political party true so many news people
are against free speech when it comes to
Islam
yeah well as my audience knows I mean
this is really where the left has failed
and from everything that I'm hearing
from my friends in the UK and across
most of Europe sadly most of Western
Europe the left is failing everywhere
and the more that the voices of liberals
are silenced the more that the far right
is going to be strengthened you're
probably somewhat of an example of that
so before we get into all the specifics
and everything that's going on today can
you just tell me a little bit of your
history growing up when you became
politically active that kind of stuff so
I grew up in a town called Luton it's
one of the most multicultural towns in
Europe when I was born in 1982 there was
one mosque now there's in excess of
thirty we have approximately 50 thousand
Muslims we've had just last week for
Muslims from my hometown one which went
went to my school have been charged with
terrorism
another young another Muslim who is a
white convert just again this this week
has been charged with inciting support
for Isis my hometown was the launch pad
for the
and seven attack on London London's
underground the fertilizer bomb plot the
Stockholm bomber some of you may
remember the Stockholm bomber he was
radicalized in my hometown he lived
doors away from my army well though
Alma's redeem you Oh mom Omar Bakri Abu
Hamza with the hook their head office
and their organization's base was in my
town so what's going on in that town
what's going on that sound is we've had
it's been the epicenter and the and the
home of radical Islam and they've been
allowed unchallenged by councils or
government or police for 30 years to
plan orchestrate and radicalize an
entire community and we've filled in my
hometown after September the 11th in
America when I come out to my shops the
next week we had magnificent nineteen
posters everywhere we had posters
glorifying the nineteen suicide bombers
that in the local college they
celebrated every year after that outside
in our town center there was a
celebration parade for the Muslims who
who murdered on September 11th that's
where I live so I've grown up from a
very young age and I have I have many of
these what we call liberals in the UK
they're not really liberals but or those
on the Left who condemn me they shout
with me they and they know nothing about
the life I've lived nothing can alter
the life I've lived they have not seen
what we've seen then I live with the
effects and when we talk about
multiculturalism in the UK like we have
our political leaders David Cameron has
come out and said multiculturalism has
failed Angela Merkel said years ago Mori
cultures in this vote what they're
actually saying what they're actually
saying is Islam's failed because in my
home town and and my group of friends
the majority of them come from immigrant
background whether it be solution
Italian Bulgarian Jamaican Indian and
everyone gets on fine and that an art my
town has been divided not through not
through racial lines ever we don't have
the racial problem and that I don't know
if you believe you may have in the US
but we don't have a racial problem we
have a religious tensions and the
religious line drawn through the
communities right so
when you saw this growing up you know
you're not you're not that old right
you're in your mid-30s when did your
sort of awakening appear when did you
say okay this is something that I have
to talk about and attach myself to so my
awakening was the bezel M school
massacre 2000 and 2004 or believe it
what it was was that I'd watched this
group this group how a measure Dean I'd
watched them grow and when I say watch
them one of the man who's convicted this
week who was next member of their
organization a white ginger convert
called Ebru Hanson his name's Roger
really firm okay
I'd watched him convert on watch him
become radical what seemed some of my
own friends who had converted in prison
and changed so I'd seen it or I'd seen
this group and then I watched an
interview after the bezler massacre
where this group was saying in my
hometown that if it happened to an
English school it would be justified and
I also knew that that group were openly
converting and recruiting in my town
center where my family go where we all
go
they were openly recruiting on the
streets every single Saturday to send
people to fight for the Taliban against
our armed forces that was it for me that
was 2004 I organized my first
demonstration I was aged 21 years old
and I organized a demonstration called
ban the loot and Taliban so it's hard to
believe that so they're actually
recruiting in a town in England for the
Taliban we know that a lot of Isis
fighters are coming from England they're
coming from all of Western Europe
basically going through Turkey right
into Syria what what does
law-enforcement do about that it sounds
like not much right I do nothing I do
nothing so but what I did when I
organized this demonstration or I
actually made leaflets over ten years
ago now and in those leaflets well we're
going back 12 years so this was before
people have heard of homegrown terrorism
in the UK before people have heard of
these organizations and in the leaflets
I made a point that our our daughters
and our sisters are being groomed which
we now know is an epidemic called
grooming which is where the groups of
Muslim men would get young girls and
they gang-raped them yeah and it's
become an epic they make across the UK
yeah it's been going on
thirty years no one's ever spoke about
now twelve years ago I made a leaflet
which went on the front page of my
national news of my local newspaper
saying whites and blacks are being
religiously target our women are being
pimped and sexually abused and put and
prostitute hid by Muslim gangs I named
the Muslim gangs I named the extremist
organizations and I stood in the town
centre I'm ready to read this leaflet
out where I said that we demand that the
police act we demand that the council's
act um there was no action after that in
fact all that happened was I was
targeted I was targeted by Muslim gangs
yeah can some of the blame here be
blamed on something related to British
society that maybe we don't have here in
America America for all our faults and
we have plenty of racial problems in all
kinds of stuff we've done the melting
pot pretty well everyone has come here
no matter where they're from and pretty
much mixed in bringing their traditions
and then and then becoming American it
sounds like an from the emails I'm
getting from Denmark and Sweden and all
this that something has happened in
Europe but I guess specifically in the
UK where for whatever reason the Muslim
population just hasn't integrated the
way that other immigrant populations
have but some of that beyond the fault
of the UK and not just the the Muslim
population yes it can yes it can be on
the fault of multiculturalists who
encouraged all these people to come here
tell them that their culture was equal
to ours told them that they can go back
into their own communities they can live
as they did in Afghanistan in Iraq and
Pakistan and as soon as anyone like
ourselves try to scratch beneath the
surface to say well let's see where we
differ
culturally let's see where our opinions
differ then we've been screened down as
racists and the reality is we need to
understand and you say it's worked
relatively well in America you have
nowhere near the percent of Muslims in
comparison to Europe and it and it will
not work well in America and that's that
that's the warning you need to realize
is that you need to learn from what's
happening over here because you're going
to face the same problems if you ever
uneducated Somalians
coming in uncontrollable numbers you
will face exactly the same problems I've
I've grown up with in Luton yeah yeah if
you allowed if you allow Saudi Arabia
you allow Qatar you allow Iran you allow
them foothold in your Khan
tree of Salafist will harvest mosques
you allow them to build schools and
teach these children hatred you will in
the next generation the experiencing the
hey that I experienced growing up so
what do you think a town like yours
where it this has been growing for a
long time as you're saying what should
be done at this point I mean these
people are citizens of the UK so what
should be done to fight these ideas not
the people but to fight these ideas that
are spreading what shouldn't be done is
my local council spend one hundred
eighty eight thousand pounds of
taxpayers money giving given to the
Salafist mosque that's a mosque that
causes us huge problem that that's a
mosque that when Ofsted went in into it
they found books in the children's
school library for how to carve hands
and feet we shouldn't be funding them we
also should not be allowing Saudi Arabia
or Qatar to fund these madrassas they're
popping up left right and centre we
should be tough on on on so many issues
we it's knowing where to start really
and I think towns that haven't had the
problems at loon have had should be
looking to our town looking at the
infiltration what we've seen is the way
the Muslims control themselves and the
way they vote then our local council no
longer care about us they don't care
because we don't keep them in power the
Labour Party are kept in power every
year in Luton by 30 to 50,000 Muslim
Oaks so we become irrelevant
and that's vote bank politics and we
don't vote based on someone's ethnicity
or we don't vote on based on someone's
religion but the Muslim community do
that's all they go yeah so you know even
as I'm talking to you I have this
feeling because I'm a liberal I have
this feeling of you know is he
exaggerating this like is this an act
you know how big is this problem you
know I follow you on twitter you tweet
videos all day long of you know women
being attacked either in the UK or in
Germany wherever and sometimes I have
trouble sort of figuring out how much of
this is actually happening all over the
place how bigger the problem is versus
is it just this micro problem
and I guess I guess your answer would be
well it's a micro problem in my town but
it's it's spreading into this big macro
thing the problem is bigger than anyone
can comprehend and that's why the
political leaders that's why police
forces that's why it's now a fact in the
UK that police social workers councils
conspired to hide these facts but for
decades
yeah can I go into that a little bit
because there's been a couple a couple
controversies about that yes so there's
been a rover M report and before this
Robin report ppb we used people used to
say I was lying or inciting hate and I
just used to say it because it happened
to my cousin these similar sort of
crimes and we knew what the police
reaction was then so there was a Robin
report an in-depth report into one
little small town in the north of
England in that small town there's a
population of male Muslims that are aged
aged between 18 to 40 there's about
3,000 now in that town they identified
1,400 young English girls who had been
beaten prosecuted and raped in
unbelievable numbers some of the girls
were raped 30 times in one night and
when they've done this big report what
they found in the report actually was
that the council knew full well the head
of the police knew the Muslim community
knew everyone knew this was happening
but the reason why they'd done nothing
was through the fear have been branded
as racists that's how powerful political
correctness is now to the circumstances
in in this report whether when the the
police turned up and there was a young
girl who was 11 years old and she's been
raped in a derelict house by five Muslim
men now when the police turned up they
arrested the girl for being drunk and
disorderly look you've got to read the
report that you've got to read the
report and also there's another
circumstance where the girl that got two
of the girls who were taken and these
girls go missing for days that 12 years
old 13 years old 14 years old they go
missing for dates yeah two of the girls
are taken so the dads went to get the
girls back the girls were inside the
house the dads have gone to the Muslims
house to get them back when the police
turned up the police arrested the
English girls dance
they left the ghost and so these sort of
things which [ __ ] your viewers said
that they sound that unbelievable right
they sound unbelievable yeah they're in
a government report this is going on
across our whole entire country this
isn't just going on in our country it's
going on in Holland
it's going on across Europe look look at
what's happening in Sweden and this is
comes from a mindset and a culture and
an ideology that teaches them that
Muslim Muslim not just what women are
inferior but not non-muslim women like
ours duh no that's happen not all
Muslims because some Muslims I've grown
up with would be as disgusted as we are
yeah but what there is a problem if you
look at the statistics for these not not
pedophilia because the majority of
pedophiles in the UK are white which
you'd expect from a 90% white country
this is a new new epidemic that men
share young children with their brothers
their cousins their work colleagues that
the level the viewing of it within the
community or within the group is not
viewed in the similar way to how we
would if a member of our community said
I've got this young 12 logo that you'd
fill them in right but this is something
very very different and it is new to the
country and what we're seeing now you've
seen it with cologne again with new easy
it's now been put in people's faces more
than ever and we feel our I feel I've
got two young daughters what two young
daughters we have two I was just
speaking before about a professor who
Angela Merkel's giving a speech this
week in a university and the professor
has stood up and he's heckled her and he
said I'm scared I have children I have
children
what what what future are you bringing
to our children this is an experiment
you know nothing about yeah and that's
the reality of it and it's not an
experiment we know nothing about we know
what's going to happen we we know what's
going to happen from case studies Luton
Town is a blueprint for the rest of the
UK it's a blueprint for the rest of
Europe it's a blueprint for America
what's happening here is happening
everywhere yeah I mean it's incredibly
chilling listening to you and again
that's why that's why I wanted to talk
to you and try to get a sense of the the
size of this whole thing I saw a video
this week did you see this a 16 year old
girl posted a video from Germany
talking about how she went to her local
supermarket and she saw these guys
staring at her and they they were
migrants and they were she really be was
afraid for her life she posted a
20-minute video on Facebook which she
clearly delineated she said I have
nothing against Muslim people she said I
have friends that are Muslim all of that
stuff she said these people these
specific people that are coming now
there's something different and from
what I understand the video was taken
down and she was at least temporarily
suspended from Facebook so that that
really shows you how perverse the
political correctness has got if now
Facebook is in on it too completely yeah
everyone keeps getting suspended for for
posting videos or pictures of the
reality and the truth that young girl my
that angers me so much more than I can
even express when I watch that and I
could well up in my eyes sitting
thinking she's not free to walk to her
shops in Germany in 2016
why is she not free because hordes of
hordes of Muslim men are coming in from
a completely different culture a
completely different view on women a
completely different that's we have to
understand their mindset and what gets
me is that look I'm all for helping
refugees these are not refugees 60
percent 60 percent this week the EU
Commissioner has come out and said
they're their economic migrants 60
percent Angela Merkel has opened those
borders to one and a half million last
year there is gonna be a flood in the
next coming years of tens of millions of
Muslims coming to our coming to Europe
come into our Colin where that girl and
her feeling is just gonna be natural to
everybody everybody's gonna be feeling
and we shouldn't feel fearful in our in
our in our own homes and towns and we do
right we do know all we have all I ever
hear about is Islamophobia all we ever
hear about is that Muslim women are
scared I'm not being funny but not no
one's raped Muslim women no one is gang
raping Muslim women no young Muslim
girls were attacked on New Year's Eve no
Muslim has had their heads head cut off
in the street no this is not happening
to Muslims and that's and that's where
when we look at the target in our I had
a meet in this week um we've lead it
with a leading of a Sikh
take organisation you should talk to
hear me he can give you real in-depth of
what's going on from a secret
perspective okay he deals with hundreds
and hundreds of young children who have
been taken from their families by Muslim
gangs and in the most recent one we're
not I went with a radio presenter and
the radio percent that said it's got
nothing to do with religion and he said
well actually everything they're saying
to the girls was raping them is about
religion yeah is the religion or race I
can go through the court cases where
there was a Somalian a smiley and rape
gang down in Bristol in the UK and he
actually said it was his religious duty
to do this it says really and these are
not what we're saying is what they're
saying they're saying you white trash
you white filth will gut you like a pig
all of these comments are being made to
these young English girls and all
everyone wants to get around the fact is
oh every one's raping everyone does it
no not ninety percent that ninety
percent of the convictions for street
gang grooming are muslim men have a
population of four percent well you know
i really am starting to see this as
almost a disease of the mind of people
on the left because even if even if
everything you were saying was being
magnified by twenty percent you know
fifty percent let's say you're totally
doubling the the severity of all of this
it's still a problem and every time i
hear my friends on the Left talk about
it they'll immediately say well you know
christianity there were the Crusades or
the catholic church has covered up
molesting children for hundreds of years
all these things no one's denying those
things right and some of those things
are still happening right now yeah but
that doesn't mean that what you're
talking about isn't a problem so my
question to you is when in the UK did
the left go off the deep end you see
what I keep trying to say and I've tried
to say for six years now this is not a
left-wing or right-wing issue because
people were automatically pigeonhole
myself as right-wing or no actually
that's a lie
I'm pigeon holders far-right right
automatically whereas the majority of
people who have supported my
organisation over the years many of them
would have been left-wing labor voters
so to be clear the reason they'd be
left-wing is because there are four
women's
rights right and they're probably for
gay rights and and they're generally for
minorities so they should fit on the
left yeah yeah
they're being pushed and forced to the
right yeah and that's because the left
in the UK politically rely and have
basically the Labour Party in the UK
then they're loyal vote bank used to be
working-class people like myself yeah
what we're in in England we have a very
classy system I don't think you
experience the same in America but we
have a very classy system at the bottom
and the top and yeah you have ways
fundamentally usually conservative
people were very wealthy and
working-class people are usually quite
poor oh no not quite poor but poor and
proud anyway but what we what we then
see is that as as working-class people
started doing better
they would then aspire to be
conservatives because they get more
money yeah right so then it seems that
low labour power just completely gave up
on this but on this section of the
community and they went straight for
which tony blair is that government who
have admitted bringing in loyal voters
which were immigrants which have now
become muslims there's one speech where
you can anyone come watch it his name
shall hit so he'd map malik and he's a
he was a Labour MP for Jewsbury and in
his speech he clearly tells us saying in
2001 we had one Muslim MP in 2004 we had
three Muslim MPs in 2008 we had eight
Muslim MPs and in between saying each
thing he says inshallah inshallah
inshallah
and he says within 15 years in this
country the majority of MPs will be
Muslim and then over the crowd which is
a thousand Muslims will cheer and clap
and then he says in in within 30 years
the prime minister of this nation will
share our faith yeah
now again I say don't listen to what I'm
saying yeah okay there's plenty of
Muslims telling and when he says this as
a representative for the Labor Party
this is the problem when you mix
religion with politics which is now
happening just it goes like this now
actually we have the Labor Party which
is the leading left-wing organization
when they have their meetings in Muslim
predominantly cities they segregate the
audiences they segregate the audiences
men and women in line with Sharia
yeah this is a party that's supposed to
stand up for women that's supposed to
stand up for gay people's Royces and
that's why I'm I have out of contempt
and disgust for what the Labour Party
and the left have now become but that
doesn't mean all left-wing people
because Islam is something that should
concern and especially the literal
interpretations of it shouldn't concern
everybody on the left and every liberal
should be screaming from the rooftops of
what's happened I know believe me
believe me I wish they were so just as
long as we're going on the political
side of this you were part of the
British National Party for a while I
think about 10 years ago and you left
because you thought they were going too
far right you thought they were becoming
racist and that caused you to leave
correct
no so what happened was that that was
when I spoke about the bedlam school
massacre in which when I was 21 I
started looking online to find who's
talking about these things
and there was only one group talking
about and they were called the British
national pie I joined the British
National Party on the twelve map there
they had a meeting so I went along to
the meeting and I joined in that meeting
in my hometown mm-hmm they then set up a
second mean where we were going to bring
our friends when I turned up with my
friends to the second meeting they said
he can't come in he can't come in it was
the black lads who seized but that's her
English that's yeah they're my best
friends so they said they can't come in
so I said what you mean they can't come
in and they saw non-white people can't
join the British National Party now I
was 21 years old never involved in
politics never an interest in politics
idea I didn't realize then that the
leader of this organisation is named
Nick Griffin I didn't realize he was a
Holocaust and lawyer I didn't realize
that I didn't realize that he used to be
leader of a National Front and asked the
organization and so from that which
there was a leaked membership list which
is how people know I was a member but I
didn't rejoin the next three years
that was my flirtation with the British
National Party was done I then in 2009
about five years later iced out the
English Defence League I set that up
based on my own principles which were
anyone can join we actually went on to
have a Sikh division a lesbian and gay
division Jewish division and anyone
that's affected by these problems
because I've grown up in the town where
I don't care about other cultures I
don't care about I don't care if you're
gay I don't care if
straight none of that bothers me yeah I
mean my problem is with this radical in
this radical ideology which is going to
cause us all serious problem so it's up
but I then did leave the English Defence
League as well yes I left in 2013 I left
because I found that a lot my time the
majority of my time actually it was not
spent trying to tackle the issues it was
spent trying to keep backward inbred
far-right Nazis out in the movement
right so that's a really interesting
point I think it sort of illuminates
your story a lot so to be clear you left
one party because they didn't want black
people basically in their party and then
when you started the EDL where you had
plenty of people from all walks of life
joining you you ended up leaving that
too because it went too far right so
when people paint you as this
ultra-right nationalist whether they
agree with all the other stuff you're
saying or not that just it just isn't
true from any estimation that I can see
anyway
anyone can spend five minutes on Google
you can go to these ultra right-wing
Nazi nationalist organizations and see
what they think of me I get just as many
death threats from them I'm known as
that I'm known as as I the real father
see what happens is I get called
far-right oh yeah the real far-right in
the UK I'm a Zionist each that that's
why I've known ask from the real farm of
course of course yeah of course
oh so real quick though on when you left
the EDL that was facilitated by a
Quilliam which is Maajid Nawaz is
organization that's trying to foster
coexistence I've had Majid on I I hugely
admire him can you just real quick
explain how he helped facilitate you
getting out I was leaving the I was
leaving the organisation anyway so I was
leaving I've made the decision I was
leaving I then met Majid Nawaz I'd known
of the organisation of some of the work
they've done anyway if I'm honest it
benefited me and it benefited him at
that time and that matters me being
completely honest are then I then spent
some time with quillian who are seen as
reformist Muslims what what I realized
then was the many of them are if they're
honest are apostates they don't follow
the teachings of Islam which is why
they're so able to say what they do but
then because of
so they're softening the blow so to
speak they're not coming out right and
saying we don't believe in this they're
saying we're trying to reform it just
cuz that's a little more palatable sort
of yeah but then their target they
actually hate it more than me then
they're actually hated more than me by
Muslims and then the more time I spent
look I Majid
Osama Hassan the summers and I'll still
say is one the most sincere decent men
I've met in my life but they they're not
being entirely honest with the public
about where we're at I've done some
training in there and I was taught that
when we talk about Islamists so that the
acceptable word now is that we're
against Islamists we're against ISM ISM
yeah which if so then what they said is
Islamist ideology and they wrote a graph
and through this chart it was punishment
for adultery punishment for
homosexuality although all the backward
ideas that come out of it but and and
they said that 90 percent of mosques in
the UK are propagating this not mighty
percent of the Muslims in the mosque
yeah but 90 percent in the mosque
because her who's funding and
controlling them and the hierarchy and
the teachers and the Imams ninety
percent of whom can't speak English Eva
then ninety percent than the most
propagating is the mists ideology and
they had Islamist ideology under false
Islam and then they had true Islam which
I said ten percent were but I said I
have a huge problem with this because if
90 percent of propagating this in the UK
that's true Islam I get what you're
trying to do and I wish you I wish you
every success in trying to change this
but without 1400 years of history that
shows it hasn't changed
you're fighting a battle now where and I
asked them when the last time I saw
Osama has and I said how many people
have you converted to your liberal form
of Islam this week because whilst you've
been doing that radical extremists in
prisons across this country and our
stores across this country have probably
conveyed thousands yeah and I want to
get to the prison part in a little bit
because you've had some completely
insane experiences in prison but just to
wrap this part up the interesting piece
here is that although you're not working
with my guys in your own way
you're both apostates to your community
he's considered you know I see all the
horrible things that people
call him porch monkey and terrible
things coming out of the the Muslim
community saying about him and coming
from white people on the left which they
considered racist if they said it about
about a black person of course but in a
way you both are now sort of outcasts
and that kind of brings you together
which to me that's where the real
conversation is whether you work with
him or kill him ever again that's that's
the blame that this has to go down the
conversation is there but this isn't a
time for conversation it's like it's if
we could rely on Muslims to solve this
problem if I'm at the opinion now we
can't unfortunately I think I spent two
years floating there with different
groups and talking to every moderate
Muslim I'm introduced to just tomorrow
night in the UK there's a BBC Radio 4
programme and I went last week because
we can and I traveled around me in
Muslim leaders again and when I met this
account where extremism counter
terrorism hailed as the most moderate of
Muslims you can get when I sat down with
him I said will you please condemn
punishment for apostasy in the Islamic
states whether that be in Saudi Arabia
just anywhere in the world please
condemn it you wouldn't do it I said you
can't even condemn that someone has the
freedom to think you can't even do that
he goes we're not there I said it that's
not hard it's not difficult either you
want people to be punished for thinking
a different way or you don't and this is
another Muslim that's hailed as the most
moderate and to be honest if I can't say
I've met one other then imagine there's
other than some of the Muslims in
Quilliam other than that older and all
the Muslims all I've met and I did push
them on questions I found out that once
I've scratched underneath the surface
actually they Hulk's um quite a few and
they do yeah and if it was time for if
Muslims could solve this problem then
the combined military force surrounding
fifty to a hundred thousand Isis
soldiers or Isis militants is up to five
million Muslims combined military force
and then they've done nothing and
they're not going to so we have we have
to do things now we have to enforce laws
we have to push agendas that are going
to make sure that we're secure and then
make sure that we we are snot just
secure but stable in the future and we
can't rely on Muslims to do okay so you
bring up some of what's going on with
the prison system in the UK you've been
to prison a couple times actually I
think about two weeks ago you might have
been in prison for a day or something is
that right
I'm always the rested up in arrested and
charged again yes yeah so I don't want
to get too much into the things that
you've been arrested for some of them
sound like extremely chumped trumped-up
charges this is a lot of what your book
is about but can you talk a little bit
about what your experience was like in
prison and how powerful the ideas of
Islamism are actually spreading in the
prison system so from the first time I'm
into custody in 2004 2005 things have
moved forward very quickly within the
prison system so wet too when I then the
next time that I went back into prison
was 2010 for actually illegally entering
America but that was in 2010 and what
I've witnessed each time I've been in
custody would terrify anyone and I
honestly say that if you could see the
maximum-security prisons with the most
dangerous prisoners and most dangerous
men in the UK are being used as Isis
training camps there Isis training camps
the white lads the black labs every one
is converting everyone has a big huge
beard is the biggest gang in the system
and it's something that the authorities
have not got grip off they can't control
the Imams god bless them some of them
are trying but they're seen as studious
- so the Imams people are not taking
their Shahada and converting to Islam in
the mosque on Friday they're doing on
the wing on the prisoners wings they run
their own mosques right so this is gonna
sound sort of amateurish because I've
never been to prison but when you've
been there what like how is it that
these ideas spread why is it that the
prison system is allowing now I know
this this is in the United States - with
okay there's all kinds of crazy
religious stuff that goes on in prisons
and drug deals and all you know it's all
nuts but what is going on that that
they're even allowing these ideas to
spread I can't stop them I can't stop
them it's it's a Islam forms of
brotherhood Australia a brotherhood you
messed with one
you mess up every Muslim so in some
instances Islam is being used within the
prison system used for power control
money it's something that anyone can
attach themselves to in it and that's
what's happened but it's also been
orchestrated and organized too you've
seen in British prisons where if a
Muslim gets another and non-muslims
convert outside sources are sending them
in money yeah so and also if you know
the ideology of Islam it's the pathway
to heaven for them
it's the pathway to heaven is to spread
Islam to spread our and to convert
prisoners but what you're seeing then is
some of the most dangerous and extreme
people in the UK are converting to Islam
and it also gives when I say it's
powerful we look in the UK we've lost
our identity through political
correctness and through years and years
have been beaten down English people
have lost their community we don't have
the community feeling that Muslim
community have and when you've lost your
identity in your tour time and time
again or you're told time and time again
that your identity and your culture and
your history is not good and then and
then comes along this this powerful
powerful community that will stick
together and we and you'll never be on
your own and it gives them everything
they've been searching for we have to
remembered a lot of people who are in
the prison system have been wronged
their whole life from a very young age
they've done a lot of wrong as well but
there's a reason many of them have chose
that path they've started with nothing
that had nothing and they've got nothing
Islam gives them a cause it gives them
something something to fight for it
gives them something to concentrate on
it and and I can
there are I've seen a lot in my life but
what I saw happening in the prison
system I don't know how we're going to
deal with it well I dunno I think steps
we can take if you look at the
statistics in French prisons out of a
population of I believe 7 percent Muslim
70 percent of the prisoners are Muslim
in the UK I spoke to prison officers who
said that in one week they had 60
conversions because a Muslim gang had
come into the prison and just started
beating an attack in everybody to
convert and then before you know it
everyone just converts further for the
easy time because if you're in trouble
and you want protection you convert so
when you're in jail speaking of being
beaten you
beaten basically to a pulp right I mean
all your teeth knocked out and really
some horrible stuff but you never
converted so how did you even or I guess
just talk about the violence that you
were subjected to first so I was in the
UK prison system they have laws and
rules that they have to follow they have
a two-tier care for every prisoner now
what they did went against every single
war so I'm under no doubt in fact if I
if I talked when I was taken to would
Hill would here was a maximum-security
presenting the UK the houses some of the
country's most feared and dangerous
terrorists I was in prison for a
financial irregularities you go to an
open prison where you got home I was
taken to a maximum security category a
prison I was putting in my cell and the
very first day when my door first opened
it was an ex-world Marine Commando who's
a priest in the British military and he
said when they come to get you from this
cell do not leave this cell what he goes
were life depends on it don't leave this
cell and then ten minutes later he's
come with two other prison officers and
said come on you're going to be winged
obviously I said I'm not going anywhere
I'm not leaving this cell yeah because I
didn't leave the cell then get arrested
so I'll get a further charge I'm
arrested and then and then I'll go to
see my solicitor at the next day and I
have a meeting with my solicitor about
what's happening when they take me back
after the meet and they open up a
waiting room and as soon as I look in
the waiting room I see the big huge
beard of a white white convert I'm put
into the room of about eight people in
it and I'm violently attacked and and
the doors locked the door was locked by
the prison officers the door was locked
and I'm left to be bit violent Libyan
and then not just that but I was
arrested again for fine they said but
but that's just one experience in the
prison system to be honest I'm lucky and
I believe that people were pulling
strings in order to have me killed and I
think even there they are scratching
their heads to how I walked out and
that's just one experience that's
happened time and time my you you said I
spent a day the other week him in
custody again yeah this was this was
quite recent just probably six months
ago I was coming to the end of my
license period with the authorities
where they have you
Oh Lord I wasn't allowed to contact
people who are in the organisation I
used to used to and this was for a
mortgage a so-called mortgage Ford here
anyone who reads my reads did there
anyone who reads the story of what
happened will see what it was all about
but I was a I was taken from the last
eight days so the last eight days I was
put back in prison I was taken to a
brick a prison called Peter Brown where
I said at the start soon as I got that I
said oh eight days left
eight days I'm gonna get killed yeah
just put me and put me in isolation it I
don't care if you don't open the door
five days you know and then eight days
let me go home I've come out of my cell
and I've told a prison officer again I
said look we know what's gonna happen
here and they've said I will have a word
and then a prisoner has come up to me
what an English prisoner and he put his
hand over his mouth he said you're gonna
get done with boiling war now in prison
in prison they put boiling water of
sugar and it takes you it will take your
face off
so I'm looking I've got two minutes to
think I said who's gonna do it
and he said the lad behind the door has
put the money up because he'd paid money
to have me her now the lab behind the
standing next door was doing 28 years in
prison for a murder where they cut a
man's nose off the guy's ears off they
killed him
now there was four of them in for that
murder I'm in for eight days I am known
as someone who has I've had a al-shabaab
of named me to be killed
I've had six government Osman warnings
saying that there's intelligence I'm
going to be murdered by Muslims and Here
I am doing eight days house with Muslim
murderers and then saw more Minds going
quick I already know that I've asked the
prison authorities to segregate me so
there's no luck there I look across and
I do what I had to do and right before
he has a chance to turn around with his
cup I strike him and then and then the
prison although there are screws the
prison officers come and jump in now I
went before the prison governor for that
offense where I explained myself I said
look you put me in this position where
I've got I have to defend myself they
decided to take no further action I was
then I was released from prison or they
went on a holiday with my wife and
children I landed back at home at Luton
Airport at midnight and the police waved
me they arrested me in front of my kids
and they arrested me for that for
attacking the Somalian prisoner who was
going to do me with boiling water they
then made a decision in October last
year of no further action so they said
we're not taking any further action I
then recently just two weeks ago I
launched a pegida UK which is a new
organization to have street
demonstrations and two days later they
come and they come Andrea rest in me for
the offense that they'd already dropped
yeah I mean this is a lot of what your
book is about and it's sort of this
endless cycle that you've you've been
part of and I know we could talk about
the prison stuff forever because you're
just scratching the surface of it but
let's talk about pegida a little bit so
I think you just got back from Germany
you were doing something with them in
Germany is that right yeah I just got
back last night so I went to Copenhagen
first where I brought british journalist
with us
so we went to Copenhagen sort of
launched Bogota in Denmark and to ask
the people to stand with us on the 6th
of February because on the 6th of
February we're planning demonstrations
in 14 countries now this is the first
time a coalition like this has been
formed and it's only been made possible
by the people by the commitment and the
people of Dresden and their leadership
have looks Backman and and the other the
others interested because for the last
year every single Monday for 53 weeks
they have taken to the streets in their
tens of thousands of times the
demonstration I just went through this
Monday there was well over 10 to 15,000
people there in a completely peaceful
civilized manner to express their their
concern free passive resistance or
what's happening so just to be clear
when when this this mass attack happened
in cologne just a couple weeks ago at
the beginning of the year it seemed like
the police were not there people did not
know who to turn to
women were literally were being raped
and attacked and all of that stuff and
then there were some demonstrations a
couple days later I think in Cologne and
some other cities and suddenly there
were a lot of police to police the
people that were there to protest the
violence that happened to the women that
really backwards here I was there at
that demonstration I know exactly what
it is when when you get large
disturbances of Muslims the police do
wait they because if they go in with
their battens if they go in and try and
police the strees they'll provoke a
right and that riot will spread and they
know that so that we've seen that many
times lockers are when we hang up here I
can send you video after video which
actually shows the police running away
in the UK now they don't run away from
us they'd knock your teeth out knock
your head off before they run away when
it comes that they're told to police the
communities differently now on New
Year's Eve the head of the police
actually asks his superiors he asks for
an extra hundred police officers he was
refused yeah and then and then what we
saw was these mass attacks and these
mass rapes of German women and you're
right they had no one to turn to and I
travelled out there for the next
demonstration and lo and behold you've
got thousands of police officers you but
war cannons and German people were
attacked with water cannons by the
police so is the situation in Germany
particularly precarious even though you
mostly focus in the UK because that's
where you're from I've heard a lot of
people say that in Germany because of
the guilt related to the Holocaust that
they they feel as a nation a certain
amount of guilt so when when these
migrants and all these people want to
come there they feel an extra need to
help them and because of that that's why
Merkel let in whatever it is I think
it's 1.2 million people and that even
when they do violent acts as a society
they're more condoning of it because
they know that their ancestors have done
some pretty horrible stuff well this
generation of Germans seem to be living
with a and suffering from guilt from
Hitler yeah the NIC generation of
Germans will suffer and live with guilt
from Angela Merkel so that's what I need
to wake up to this generation have
nothing to feel guilty about they have a
beautiful country a beautiful culture
the envy of the world
they're beautiful people beautiful such
civilizing decent people and they have
nothing to feel guilty of so what this
isn't is an underestimation of the
culture and ideology they're allowing it
that's what it is like if everyone's all
make you human responses we must help
these people but not help them if it
involves the destruction
your culture and your and your country
not help them at their cost or the
expense of young German girls but and
I'm all for helping refugees I just
don't think they should be helped in
Europe I think they should be helped in
the Middle East I think that we should
be leading the way in funding and
military support to make sure that there
are buffer zones but I don't think that
important and to be honest by important
1.2 million ich is she making any impact
on the suffering of refugees across the
Middle East because there's tens of
millions yeah and what other option is
there bring bring the whole of Syria
into Europe it solves nothing
it's all and what she's actually done by
doing this is she's opened up the
floodgates and we will now see absolute
stampy's of tens of millions over the
next five years well I've also read a
bunch on how it's not just about the
violence but also just the actual system
the systems that are in place the social
systems you know I was reading something
this morning about how all of these
people that are coming from Syria they
all a huge percent of them have really
bad teeth their teeth are really bad now
they're gonna get free dental coverage
and it's gonna cost some nicely was
something like a billion euros or
something but they're not gonna pay for
it so the average German taxpayer is
gonna have have to pay for it and then
that right there when their taxes go up
then naturally they're gonna be more
resentful of these people so it's it's
hitting people in the at the economic
level and at the violent level it just
seems like a terrible mix it's gonna
society it's going to hit them
everywhere
I believe 80% of them can't read or
write I believe that many of the real
refugees have come from Syria are going
to be suffering from PTSD post-traumatic
stress stress disorder
they're gonna need counseling they're
gonna need help there's so many problems
that will come from this yeah and we say
1.2 million but they're allowed to bring
their families after three years right
and their lap and they're allowed their
EU passports so that 1.2 will become 6
or a it doesn't have the infrastructure
simply but what Angela mark was fully
aware of is that they won't stay in
Germany they're gonna come to countries
like mine yes she knows she knows and in
fact just last week the German
government have come out and said we've
lost 600,000 refugees we've lost them
asylum seekers we've lost them they're
not where they said they were
now 600,000 how many of them are rapists
how many are Isis fighters how many are
criminals we have no idea no idea at all
so let me ask you this because a lot of
this you know at some level you hear the
people throwing around the term Trojan
horse a lot and a lot of it sort of
sounds like a conspiracy that there has
been this organized effort to just
influx all these people and I think I've
seen even in some of the videos that
you've tweeted when you see just like
hundreds or thousands of migrants
crossing it does seem like it's eighty
or ninety percent men men that are
twenty or thirty you don't see a lot of
women you see occasionally you'll see
some women and some children but it does
seem like a lot of men but to go that
route it sounds like a conspiracy theory
to go and say oh this is there's an
intentional plan to flood Europe with
these people to ultimately take over but
I suspect by the fifty minutes we've
spent together you don't think it's much
of a conspiracy hmm that can be now of a
reason anyone with any common sense and
intelligence or brain can can look at
what's happening and know it's not going
to be good for Europe well anyone can
look at what's happening Angela Merkel
made comment such as immigrants are more
prone to violence and extremism than on
immigrants she said that years ago she's
also made comments saying that
multiculturalism is biology they've
already failed to integrate millions of
Muslims so why is she bringing millions
more what reason are if anyone can Alex
can give a reason and how are these
millions well what do you think what do
you think actually what do you think is
going on in her head then we if
everything you've said here is true
angle and Merkel she was just time woman
of the year right I mean this is a this
is a bright lady right so Angela Merkel
has no children and she cares not for
the future of our country or our people
that's truthfully what I feel I don't
think she cares about about the future
of her people and at the same time you
have this this as you said people
holding her up on a pedestal at first at
first
whatever it was fruit in wall tech I
can't say it was fruit real intention
because I think they know they everyone
knows full well what this is gonna do to
Europe we know full well what's gonna
happen and what you're seeing is that
actually the only countries in Europe
that are freely speaking honestly
are the countries that don't have a
rather high percentage of Muslims its
Poland its Hungary its Czech Republic
its Slovakia their political leaders are
coming out and saying what needs to be
said now if you look at the UK he's
former political leaders if you look at
Sir William Gladstone he held the Koran
above his head he's in Parliament and he
said that Islam this this Quran is a
violent and a cursed book and will never
be a peace on this earth so long as we
have this book Winston Churchill said
that individual Muslims will show
amazing characteristics but the the
backwardness of Islam has the power to
bring Europe back to the dark ages now
there are two world leaders we have
statues on that the whole world loves
and if they were around today they will
be called bigots
yeah an extremist and that's simply for
telling the truth my prime minister
my prime minister says that Islam is a
religion of peace and the facts speak
very different to that and at the moment
the problem we have is that by telling
the truth which even if people don't
like the truth we have to be honest I
also think when people say Islam is a
religion of peace or Christian is
original at peace or Judaism is a
religion of peace it's a moot point a
religion is because a religion is only a
set of ideas all a religion is is what
its adherents do right it's a religion
of peace that that means nothing that an
idea is what people do with it
so I find those statements like that
just don't add anything to the
conversation no and we hear them after
every terrorist attack every single
terrorism so that's what we that's what
we talked and in fact it's not all we're
told about I'll give you two other
circumstances now as a parent has it
that I was studying the biography of
Mohammed yeah and I'm sad I'm and I'm
preparing for a debate and my daughter
who is eight years old she walked past
me and said because I don't I never
taught my children a thing my kids never
heard of the English Defence League yeah
I have I lived two very separate lives
and I want to protect them for as long
as possible from understanding these
politics my daughter walked past and
said Muhammad peace be upon him and I
looked her and I said what did you just
say and why did you just say that and
she said well as tall as school we have
to say peace be upon him I said peace be
upon him
and then and that sauce is one instant
then in that another instant that about
a mosque and then when I took my
children to look at another school and
one of the things that one of the things
they had to do was put the different
religious buildings with the different
widgets words yeah
the only one my daughter could do the
religions of the world was his mom
because what's happening now in the
national curriculum in the UK is that
Islam is the favored religion Islam is
what's being pushed and propagated to
all of our youth and children and
they're brainwashing I don't mind if
they want to talk about Mohammed tell
the truth yeah tell us about the man he
was not a man of peace some of the
things he done was some sort such
immoral things no he killed a lot of
people there's no I don't think that's a
fact it's a fact but they're not
teaching that they're teaching that this
is this great man this great man
Mohammed that we must all respect and
say peace be upon him that's what
they're teaching eight-year-old English
children so then by the time that next
generation come out of the schools
they've been brainwashed into this
mindset and and as soon as your parents
even I've seen it across the country
parents who have not not wanted their
children to be taught these things and
then branded as racist as well I'm all
for the truth being taught to my kids
but then I then haven't even spoke to my
children if I haven't spoke to my
children about Islam well that's one of
the strange things and I think we see
this a little bit in America where
they'll say well we need to learn more
about Islam because of this and to me
it's like we should not be learning more
about Islam we should not be learning
more about Christianity we should not be
learning more about Judaism or Mormonism
or Jainism or any of them what we should
be learning about our secular values we
should be learning about the things that
tie us together not all the little
differences that are just going to split
us I'm completely in agreement it's just
a fundamental problem or I always say
that I believe in secular schools I
think we should have secular schools but
then I don't believe we should also I
don't believe that should pose pose a
problem for seek to for seek schools or
Hindu school or Christian schools
because because they're not causing us
the problems that we face these huge
problems that we face currently are
caused by Islam they're inspired by
Islam and if they want to sit in schools
and talk about Mohammed they need to
tell them that he raped a child he
married a child he
murder that they need to tell the truth
and then not so then we have this
complete watered-down educational system
there is line to the next generation of
youth in the UK yeah all right well we
have to wrap up and I feel like there's
so much more we could talk about and and
hopefully with the way I preface this
whole episode people will learn about
you and they can make the decisions you
know whether they think you're racist or
whether they think you're you're
preaching the truth or somewhere in
between but just to wrap up give me
something that you think give me some
hope here give me some hope I mean
you're working with pagina now doesn't
sound like a hate organization to me so
give me some hope for an ability to turn
some of this around and for some
coexistence Europe is waking it up
hugely the people of Europe you've just
seen a declaration called the fortress
Europe which is a it's called the Prague
declaration which 14 different countries
now have assigned to on the 6th of
February for the first time there's
going to be demonstrations in England in
Holland in Denmark in Germany in the
Czech Republic in Poland all
simultaneously at the same time this is
the star of a friendship and
partnerships being built across Europe
not just Europe actually Australia also
marching with us we hope that by the
next time we have America we hope we
have Canada we have India we have the
world because this is a worldwide
problem we have to face and then yeah
there is hope and then always be hope
because it to be honest I know how
hardly that our love for freedom and our
love for democracy will always that way
they're there their hatred and walk for
Sharia yeah all right well listen it was
really interesting talking to you and
I'm sure we'll keep talking but I was
gonna send people to Amazon to buy your
book but Amazon took your book off
didn't they they took it off and put it
back up three times right so I'm not
sure if it's up right now but they can
definitely get your book at Tommy
Robinson dot Co UK and they can get the
Kindle version at least Indo in American
Amazon yeah all right well it was a
pleasure talking to you and you know
it's difficult stuff but that's why we
have to have these conversations so I
thank you for coming on